sind wir kurz vor der entdeckung des
mysteriösen planeten 92 astronomen haben
nun eine himmelskarte oder wie sie
selbst sagen eine schatzkarte
veröffentlicht die den wahrscheinlichen
orbit und aufenthaltsort von planet 9
offenbart schon in den kommenden zwei
jahren soll der bislang nur theoretisch
vorhergesagte planet endlich aufgespürt
werden warum die forschenden jetzt auf
piraten bei der suche setzen darüber
gibt es jetzt mehr infos in klicks
umsatz im tschad hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen irgendwo da draußen
im kuipergürtel könnte sich der ominöse
planet 9 verbergen ein neptun großer
planet über dessen existenz fachleute
weltweit bereits seit vielen jahren
spekulieren dazu schreibt einer der
beiden entdecker von planet neuen der us
astronom michael braun in seinem blog
vor fünf jahren haben wir erstmals die
existenz von planeten vorgeschlagen
jetzt haben wir die vielleicht
wichtigste etappe bei der konkreten
suche danach geschafft wir wissen jetzt
wo wir suchen müssen und tatsächlich
könnte der ominöse planet 9 der sonne
näher kommen als gedacht wo er zurzeit
stecken könnte und auch wie sein orbit
aussehen könnte genau dazu gibt es jetzt
aktuelle erkenntnisse befinden wir uns
somit auf der zielgeraden bei unserer
spannenden suche nach planeten
alle wichtigen infos zu diesem
spektakulären thema gibt es jetzt hier
bei pixum science in future wer oder was
ist planet 9 fachleute weltweit gehen
davon aus dass es sich um einen
gesteinsplaneten
mit dem vierfachen ehrt durchmesser
handeln könnte achtung mit der 5 fache
masse der erde frühere berechnungen
legen nahe dass er 10.000 bis 20.000
jahre brauchen könnte um die sonne in
einer langgezogenen umlaufbahn zum
runden versteckt halten könnte er sich
im sogenannten kuiper gürtel diesen kann
man sich wie eine ringförmige zone am
außenrand unseres sonnensystems
vorstellen doch diese sogenannten
transnet tonigen objekte sind super
schwierig aufzuspüren denn sie befinden
sich ja jenseits von neptun und sind
extrem licht schwach von der sonne sind
sie zu weit entfernt als dass sie
genügend licht taktieren würden auch
deshalb konnte planet 9 trotz intensiver
forschung nicht aufgespürt werden bisher
wenn es ihn denn überhaupt gibt denn
seine existenz ist bis heute umstritten
mit gängigen planeten bildungs modellen
ist es kaum zu erklären wie ein planet
in eine solch ungewöhnliche umlaufbahn
kommen kann handelt es sich etwa um
einen eingefangenen exoplaneten oder
liegt es an steuereffekten des jupiters
oder ist es ein schwarzes loch
hypothesen dazu gibt es reichlich seit
2016 spekulieren forschende ob es diesen
neptun großen planeten wirklich gibt
doch klar ist seine existenz könnte sehr
auffällige bahn abweichung mehrerer
größerer objekte im kupfergürtel erklärt
astronomische beobachtungen konnten
bereits zeigen dass es ausreißer
planeten mit ähnlich weiten orbitz auch
um andere sterne herum gibt ende des
vergangenen jahres hatte ein
internationales astronomenteam einen
exoplaneten identifiziert der auf einer
ähnlich ungewöhnlichen bahn kreist wie
der hypothetische planet neuen konkret
geht es um einen gasriesen mit der
bezeichnung hd 1 0 6906 b teil eines 3
136 lichtjahre entfernten
doppelsternsystems seine existenz belegt
dass planeten mit so exotischen fernen
umlaufbahn existieren können und genau
das macht auch den hypothetischen
planeten in unserem sonnensystem
zumindest ein stück wahrscheinlicher
dennoch trotz intensiver suche bleibt
der riesen planet ein phantom dabei
mangelt es nicht an verschiedenen
anhaltspunkten indizien für seine
existenz spricht beispielsweise die
ansammlung von kleinen himmelskörpern
jenseits des neptun denn deren baden
sind im vergleich zum rest des
sonnensystems äußerst ungewöhnlich und
genau das könnte nach ansicht von
fachleuten an der anziehungskraft eines
bisher unbekannten planeten liegen doch
warum werden wir einfach nicht fündig
das liegt zum einen an seinem möglichen
aufenthaltsort schätzungen zufolge
könnte sich der culpa gürtel über eine
gewaltige länge von 6 milliarden bis 50
milliarden kilometern ziehen dazu kommt
planet 9 liegt enorm weit weg von der
sonne so dachte man bisher doch die
beiden us-wissenschaftler mike brown und
konstantin bettingen vom california
institute of technology caltech geben
die suche einfach nicht auf und kam so
jetzt auf neue spannende erkenntnisse
die beiden forscher waren es übrigens
auch die im jahr 2000 16 das erste mal
die existenz eines potenziellen neunten
planeten postuliert hatten sie sind also
bereits seit mehreren jahren daran
interessiert endlich den mysteriösen
planeten 9 zu finden doch jetzt heißt es
in ihrem blog dass der wichtigste teil
der suche wohl abgeschlossen werden
konnte zitat wir wissen jetzt wo wir
suchen müssen wir hatten seit jahren
zwar eine ziemlich gute vorstellung
konnten aber nicht wirklich die
unsicherheiten einschätzen wo sich
planet 9 am himmel befinden könnte
welche masse er hat und wie er sein
könnte das können wir jetzt dabei gab es
erst im märz diesen jahres einen
riesigen rückschlag für die jägerinnen
und jäger vom planet neuen wir hatten
hier bei pixum suns in future darüber
berichtet ein us forschungsteam hatte
die datenlage und untersuchung zu den
bahnen von 14 extremen tn aus genauer
ins visier genommen timo steht für
transnet typische objekte meint damit
also alle die weit jenseits des neptuns
kreisen die analyse offenbarte dass die
bahnen diese objekte auch ohne die
anwesenheit eines namen planeten erklärt
werden können das forschungsteam kam
dabei zu dem schluss dass die extrem
tieren aus gleichmäßig über den himmel
verteilt sind dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler das
bedeutet nicht dass kann nicht neun
nicht da ist doch seine anwesenheit ist
nicht notwendig um die daten zu erklären
doch mike brown und konstantin bett
liegen ließen sich davon nicht
beeindrucken sie sind von der existenz
vom kleinen 9 überzeugt doch wo genau
hält er sich versteckt und wo sollten
wir nach ihm suchen genau diese fragen
wollen die beiden astronomen jetzt
endlich beantwortet haben sie haben nun
eine himmelskarte veröffentlicht die den
wahrscheinlichen orbit und
aufenthaltsort vom planet 9 offenbart
die beiden forscher sprechen von einer
zitat schatzkarte in modellsimulationen
hatten die beiden wissenschaftler also
das ziel den wahrscheinlichsten orbit
für den hypothetischen planeten zu
ermitteln welche umlaufbahn also kann
die bewegung von 11 kupfergürtel
objekten mit weiten orbitz und bahn
abweichungen am besten erklären dabei
gingen die fachleute zum einen von
verschiedenen möglichen größen und zum
anderen von verschiedenen möglichen
massen außerdem zogen sie auch
schwerkraft effekte der planeten und
auch andere mögliche einflussfaktoren
mit in ihrer analyse ein wenn man davon
ausgeht dass kann nicht neun neptun ist
und über rund 6,2 erdmassen verfügt
hätte seinen orbit eine große halb achse
von rund 380 astronomischen einheiten
wir brauchen am betteln jetzt in ihrer
aktuellen studie schreiben demnach
könnte sich der planet 9 auf einem
exzentrischen orbit zwischen einem
sonnennächsten punkt bei 300
astronomischen einheiten und einem
sonnenfenster punkt bei 450
astronomischen einheiten bewegen eine
astronomische einheit ist dabei der
mittlere abstand von erde und sonne
planeten ist also ziemlich weit entfernt
eine weitere berechnung haben die beiden
forscher für den fall aufgestellt das
planet 9 weniger masse hat als man
vermutet wenn er nur 2,2 erdmassen
schwer ist dann könnte in diesem fall
der sonne sogar auf 85 astronomische
einheiten nahe kommen dazu heißt es vom
forschungsteam wir stellen fest dass die
große halb achse im mittel signifikant
näher liegt als zuvor angenommen auch
wenn die spanne der möglichen entfernung
noch groß ist die beiden wissenschaftler
selbst sind überrascht dass die neu
berechnete umlaufbahn planet 9 näher an
die sonder heranbringen könnte als man
bislang dachte für die umrundung der
sonne braucht er demnach nicht 10.000
bis 20.000 jahre so wie man es bisher
angenommen hat er möglicherweise sind es
nur sieben 1400 jahre das würde die
suche nach planeten vereinfachen wenn er
also wirklich existiert könnte er schon
in naher zukunft aufgespürt werden
beispielsweise mit der hilfe des wehrer
houben auf satorius schon in zwei jahren
2023 soll das spiegelteleskop in betrieb
genommen werden wie schnell er wirklich
entdeckt wird hat natürlich auch mit
seiner größe und helligkeit zu tun dazu
braun und bettingen in der hellsten
variante könnte planet 9 sogar schon in
den aufnahmen verschiedener
himmelsdurchmusterungen präsent sein
doch wo hält sich planet 9 also gerade
versteckt dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam leider verraten uns
unsere daten nur den orbitalen fahrt
nicht aber wo auf dieser umlaufbahn der
planet gerade ist es ist
wahrscheinlicher dass planet 90 zurzeit
nach dem golden fernsten punkt seiner
bahn bewegt einfach weil er dort
langsamer ist uns sich daher länger dort
aufhält das such areal für planet 9
konnte damit also stark eingegrenzt
werden brown bezeichnete das ganze als
schatzsuche die aktuellen ergebnisse und
die erstellte himmelskarte könnten also
eine art schatzkarte seien für die suche
nach planeten alle beteiligten piraten
sollen jetzt an dieser schatzsuche
teilnehmen so die aufforderung der
beiden planet neun jäger damit planet 9
schneller gefunden wird planet 9 seine
bahn verläuft anders als bisher gedacht
hier gibt es nochmals in diesem video
mehr infos zu seiner vermutlichen bahn
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren unter
jedem video gibt es übrigens dafür den
abo button oder hier das ist komplett
kostenlos also einfach draufklicken und
macht schlau bis dann bleibt dran